different weapons what happens when you
put a bow against the pistol giant
battle axe against a crossbow or a
minecraft sword against captain
america's shield
i really i really want to slap somebody
with this
you might think that a gun always beats
a knife but in reality once you're below
21 feet in distance that changes
significantly whenever they're training
police on how to deal with people with
weapons and things like that they always
tell them to keep 21 feet apart a while
back on node we tried a video called the
21 foot rule problem with that video is
that we were in a hallway and we kind of
knew who would be attacking and the
element of surprise really kind of
increases the chance of success for the
melee weapon guy we are reintroducing
the element of surprise any one of these
people might be attacking me and i do
not know which one it is until the
time's up i expect him to attack me
right now it's going to get ready
all right
we gotta conceal who gets the knife
chris don't we have two knives
can we just like go two knives right we
have one knife why don't we do our
favorite city can we just start sneaking
up on them
clearly one of them's going to attack me
when i least expect it as they walk over
here
i know these guys i know their tricks
they're gonna be ready for them they're
deviously planning everyone
[Music]
right here
easily i told you i wasn't even looking
he just took me down
oh man
so i would call that last scenario that
i would call that scenario a you're at
the grocery store you're comfortable
[Laughter]
should we amp it up a little bit i just
should take it to 22 feet sponsored
segment
that's right today's sponsor is mile 22
the film which is an intense action
thriller that premieres august 17th it's
directed by peter berg so you know it's
going to be badass and it has an
all-star cast including mark wahlberg
lauren cohen ronda rousey john malkovich
and making his american film debut
eco-us from the raid if you haven't seen
that movie definitely go and check it
out anyway this movie has intense close
quarters combat scenes which is
inspiring this event going on here today
it also has high-tech assault weaponry
and of course hand-to-hand martial arts
if you want to go see it definitely go
and do that on august 17th and without
further ado let's get started and see
which one of these weapons is the most
deadly from 22 feet apart different
weapons what happens when you put a bow
against the pistol giant battle axe
against a crossbow or a minecraft sword
against captain america's shield
i don't know
dude
[Music]
dude one person in the middle 22 feet
apart different weapons
and see which one is the deadliest
man i want that money
game on red can strike at any moment
just warming up here i like how you're
facing me you're so worried
dude i saw it out of the corner of my
eye
dude dude i knew the shotgun was the
right call i didn't bite my tongue son
you better bite your tug boy
i'm gonna get ruined
i'm gonna get ruined i don't stand a
chance
hey [ __ ] hey
does this shot work is this shot working
the noisy cricket beats the lightsaber
does it does it count that i retreated
yeah you survived great he swung
there was like that much space
never been so scared in my life now
watch with crazy technology nowadays
don't put it into my phone put it into
my phone
flip the chip over and put it in back
into my phone
all right i think we've seen very
clearly how this has been functioning
now let's do one more round everyone
picks their favorite weapon i think i'm
gonna go for this no no no no this is
mine
say hey hey hey you can't have that one
oh hey hey hold on hold on hold on
hold
on
hold
on
no you can't have that though hey hey
hey hey hey hey guys guys
i can trust you right everyone calm down
everyone calm down
ring true
i hear you
a blind man with a boat a blind bow man
i hear you
i hear you
i hear you oh i can i'm not blind
[Laughter]
there was just a ruse
he wasn't blind at all
the real winner of this is nick i'm
sorry ghost michael
don't do that to me man that's it i hope
you learned something about melee versus
deranged weapons and remember mile 22 is
in theaters august 17th
now on to a very special segment with
our producer friend jude
you guys remember that conversation we
had with jude that really good interview
where he had dropped a lot of wisdom
bombs on us filmmakers there's actually
a lot more interesting things that were
part of that conversation that didn't
quite include because they weren't quite
on topic but still really interesting
for example what was the worst injury
you've seen on set or who was the most
famous person you worked with and were
they cool
we're actually going to jump back to
that conversation and have some of these
questions that were really fun and i
should mention jude read all the
questions you guys posted in that
previous video and he'll read all the
questions from this video and we'll have
him come back and we'll have him answer
your questions throw your feet up kick
back sit back and listen to jude drop
some more wisdom bombs on you may not be
able to answer the question on the
camera what's the worst injury you've
ever had to deal with on something
well i was on a set it wasn't my set
thankfully but i was on this movie
called andersonville that was uh
directed by john frankenheimer
who is legendary uh oscar ward winning
director and it was produced by jane
fonda and ted fonda we shot in georgia
and they called lunch and we were
shooting night shoots so we say lunch
but it's like two in the morning right
so this guy it was raining and they were
up above the pine trees in georgia about
70 feet up in the air on a crane and
they called lunch
and one of the camera ops was so excited
about lunch he took his harness off
while the crane was coming down and he
fell oh dang face planted from 60 feet
up on the
ground and the helicopter lifted him out
and and i don't know if he i don't know
if he died i'm assuming he probably did
because that's a huge fall
but they you know they shut down the set
and they they were like you know we're
not gonna shoot for a couple days and
blah blah and it really affected
everybody because i don't know some of
you guys may know that in the film
industry there was a sarah jones thing
where she was on the train tracks and
she got hit and it caused this huge
ripple effect
through the industry
um
that uh
that uh for safety so that was a that
was a bad one and then i was on an
indian movie
uh that we were shooting on a stage and
someone was up on a big train there's a
lot of crane accidents
and they have a weight a counterweight
system right which is like a ballast
because the weight of the camera goes up
and stuff and usually there's people on
it so there was a guy up on the camera
crane uh and they they said pack up back
up they pack up for the day which is
like our wrap we say rap they say pack
up and uh
the guys down there started taking the
weights off oh no so basically they took
the weights off and the camera went
down and that guy didn't make it really
yeah
so i've seen some stuff and and uh
you know i've been around for some other
injuries and stuff but those two i mean
it's just brutal when someone like in in
the end it's it's a it's a product
that's going to go on a screen and it's
not worth dying over and i i say that to
a lot of people too because in the film
you know it's so much money and time and
stress people are always like ah and i
always say look
we're we're not saving lives here you
know we're not we're not doctors and
emts and policemen and
and uh military but this is just
entertainment uh beef tacos and one idol
beef taco and hopefully through uh
interviews like this and talking jude
you guys are getting a little bit of a
deeper understanding and more
appreciation out of your movies we're
trying to make your movies better for
you
if you know what's going on behind the
scenes you can enjoy your movies even
more i think you will definitely
appreciate them more because you'll know
all the work and sacrifice on all ends
you know creative and
financial ends logistic ends every
everyone's sort of making a compromise
but the compromise is for the better
just like your relationship with your
girlfriend your boyfriend or your wife
or your dog it's like
you constantly have to change it you
know to make it better but in the end
it's the greatest thing that ever
happened to you so that's kind of what
we're doing with movies yeah so we got a
bunch of tacos
i think these are my beef tacos these
are the idol ones these are definitely
the vegans
what like what have you worked on like
you worked at any like hollywood movies
like what's the biggest movie you've
worked on like anything conventional
that we would know absolutely um well i
started in the business you know
basically getting the coffee i was a pa
and production assistant
and making phone calls and stuff
and
but those were a much bigger studio uh
pictures so like the first one i ever
did was probably one of the biggest it
was called bicentennial man with robin
williams and it was like 125 million
bucks which back then was huge now
that's not really that big with all the
marvel movies and stuff so i did that
and then
i i got under the wing of some people at
fox so i started working on a bunch of
fox stuff so dude where's my car was a
big one i did
which was really fun that was a really
great experience because the crew really
bonded
um the whole thing in fact danny liner
the director became one of my really
good friends and i took him to thailand
and he also did harold and kumar and
some sopranos and stuff
but other movies high crimes with ashley
judd morgan freeman i did the wash with
snoop and dre
i did uh united states of leland that
had ryan gosling and kevin spacey and
michelle williams and
chris klein and jenna malone and on and
on and on
so yeah that's some of them i mean i
i've got i probably got 75 feature film
credits and another 25 that i'm not
credited on so over 100 films over the
last
two and a half three decades um
so i'd have to look at my raccoons that
they all blended together but those are
some of the big ones off the top of my
head
yeah
so i was there
oh yeah i just remembered some more
um so i did wedding planner
that had jlo and matthew mcconaughey i
did woman on top which sounds like a
porn but it's not it's um it's actually
the first american film that uh penelope
cruz did
she used to be a star of course overseas
and all the spanish-speaking countries
um so it was her first american film
um we shot in san francisco
she was awesome
it's really great
shout out penelope you guys think these
tacos are delicious
i like the potato ones that's cool
like i grew up
i grew up in georgia but my family was
up in pennsylvania so they're it's like
polish lithuanian slavic all that so
they have a lot of potato stuff potato
pancakes potato pierogies and all that
so it's like that by putting a southwest
flare on it
yeah
good
burning question on my mind
because who's the most famous person you
worked with
you know and were they cool and what
were they like okay this is a good one
because it's also topical
well i mean there's so many
that i've worked with but the coolest
ones i gotta say
you know there's this whole metoo
movement going around so that's i find
it interesting because some of these
guys
i know
and i'm not saying that uh
that they didn't do these things but i
have totally different experiences with
them obviously i'm not a hot chick so
that's probably why
but uh like for example kevin spacey's
and was an amazing person on set really
cool and same with morgan freeman
they were both
you know two of the coolest in my top
five
uh of people that i work with um
but
you know i work with ashley kutcher and
sean williams scott
and uh what's your name um
jennifer garner on that and back then
ashton was really full of himself
because it was like the first thing he
did off of that 70s show so he had been
a model
and then he went to do that 70s show so
he was like well i'm just mr perfect and
he is but you're not supposed to know
that about yourself
so
um you know but but eventually he turned
into the person who he is now which is
really cool and down there that's i
generally find that in the business
which is really interesting because i
find that the old g's
are really nice because they've been
around the block they've already done
the fame thing they've gotten the ego
out of their heads they're cool it's the
young guys that are like the best thing
on the planet and you know they really
think like that so
that's my experience i've also worked
with a lot of influencers you know you
guys of course and then like uh roman
atwood
furious pete harley morningstein the
epic meal time crew jenna marbles
um tobuscus a bunch of those guys again
so
you know all over the place um
but famous people yeah there's a million
i don't know i could i could pull out my
mbb and i could go through them real
quick
uh do you happen to
find a difference
when working with influencers versus uh
celebs oh absolutely um
in two two two ways a lot of ways
actually i think um
you know ratio wise
ratio wise now an influencer makes more
money that doesn't mean they make more
money over and all obviously a celeb
getting 20 million dollars i worked with
j.lo for example and matthew mcconaughey
on the wedding planner obviously they're
getting a lot of money but but work to
money ratio i think influencers make a
lot more because they can put out a
video and it becomes viral and then they
get kickback from that right whereas as
a celebrity you might have to be on a
project for three months you know so
um a youtuber can put out a video every
week you know what i mean so
what what the result of that is is that
these young influencers don't know any
better and they're not told any better
so they come to set obviously thinking
they're the a-list talent and they may
be for that brand or whatever but the
crew is professional the studio is
professional even if it's you know like
youtube or facebook or hulu or whoever
the generally the people they hire are
professionals in the business so you
have a young guy or woman coming in and
they're like hey this is well we shoot
this in an alleyway we shoot at a taco
stand this is how we do it like you know
you can't tell us what to do but we
we've had things that have been in place
you know the film business been around
since the 1920s since like the charlie
the talky days
charlie chaplin and all that so i think
there's things that and the film borrows
a lot from the military right like the
timings and the structure and the
hierarchy that's a big one and i feel
like of course if you're an actor and
you came up through sag and all that
stuff you know this system and you know
the hierarchy and you know your place
and you know who to go to if there's a
problem or a concern or a complaint but
if you're an influencer you don't know
this world at all you're just thrown
into this already systematic world and
it's very difficult for a lot of them to
adjust like we've had a lot of problems
uh dealing with influencers on various
shows but
eventually the smart ones come around
and they're like okay i can do that for
this system and they know okay maybe
maybe this particular show is not
offering me as much money as i'm making
on my personal videos but i know it's a
big opportunity to get myself seen out
there and more and more people so they
they sort of step in line but i think
that's important especially for people
my age like it's a whole generational
thing
and is that a word generational thing
and uh yeah so it's a whole generational
thing and
and uh so we're like when i came up
there was no digital right it was all
film so to get in the business was
really hard and it was extremely
structured and you had to prove yourself
constantly and constantly now there's so
much digital content that there's stuff
shooting constantly so you could get in
the business and be in the business but
not necessarily have that uh same
background and structure which is good
and bad it's great that people have
opportunity like uh you come and be in
the business like i love that i love
that someone can now doesn't have to
hire a helicopter they can get a drone
shot that's just as good if not better
because they can shoot lower
or that you know you can get your
parents to buy you a digital camera or
save some money and and buy one and do
some awesome stuff and there's we're
seeing amazing content coming from
people
you know in iowa and milwaukee and
places that aren't even production hubs
which is awesome but when you transition
into that professional world and
professional set you should respect the
craft because everyone that's there
usually has a long resume and has dealt
with people who have way more experience
so you kind of got to know your place
in it that would be some advice for me
if you're trying to you know get into
business
it's interesting
so
let me eat this real quick
you're talking about youtube influencers
yeah the things that come to mind is
there's a thing called the adpocalypse
that happened you've probably heard of
it oh yeah yeah right basically youtube
got more stringent on their their
guidelines so yeah
you have guns in your video yeah you get
the amount of times you have violence
here swear words etc yeah
now
in the film industry
you have things like horror movies i
mean you just went out in a horror movie
i'm assuming there's probably boobs in
it there's probably a lot in that
check check so
that's like the exact opposite of what
youtube's pushing for like how do you
how do you go and you make how do you go
and make something that's not family
friendly how do you actually find a
market for this how do you get it made
well that's a very interesting point and
i would say i'm i'm also learning about
this even though i'm a veteran in the
business it's ever changing because of
the dynamics of social media and digital
uh
you know distribution basically so
that's constantly changing the good news
about independent films like mine like
the incantation is that you can be edgy
and and audiences want to see that they
want smart stuff they want cutting edge
stuff they want controversial stuff
right so like for mine for example i got
dean kane who used to play superman back
in the 90s right so he has this like
spit shine polished pretty boy innocent
image that he always has to do for the
studios right he's in a million shows
he's in hallmark shows and he plays the
cop and the dad and whatever in mind
he's pretty much the opposite of that
he's pretty much the devil right
and there's like human sacrifices and
some blood and some occultish and some
witch stuff and all that so
that's the beauty of independent is that
if you can somehow get the money
together or the finance or anybody to do
your film even if it's small the
audience is out there they're hungry for
that stuff like like look at american
horror stories some of you guys might
watch that right like that's real like
they got nuns like having sex with
people and chopping up bodies and like
stuff you would never see in a studio
like definitely not family friendly but
the investors know that that kind of
stuff catches on with people right so
they love that edgy content
but it's not necessarily the studio way
like you said so you can go the nd way
and get distribution like we did
or you can go with the studio system and
have 10 people saying you can't say the
word darn
no too
edgy okay that makes sense so you have
to really kind of connect with that
niche audience you're going to make a
niche product you do and and there's a
demographic out there for that find your
demographic make the product towards
that demographic and then push it
which comes to marketing which is kind
of what this is part of our marketing
too like marketing is a big thing and
when you're a small indie like if you
make a film on your iphone for example
or on your little uh 7s
you have to market that yourself even if
you get a distributor how do you do that
how do you get it out there you do that
by word of mouth so you go to like all
these review sites right like i've
contacted i've sent i've literally said
i'm not exaggerating probably 900 to
1000 emails in the last five months and
i contact them all and i said hey do you
want to see my movie you want to screen
it you want to look at the trailer and
then maybe
20 of them get back and maybe of those
20 half of those actually do it and
maybe three of those three percent of
those don't even do it even though they
said they would so it's a constant
uh
battle you know it's like it's like when
you go like if you're in your job and
you
you travel somewhere and you give out
your business cards to everybody and
everyone's like oh okay well i don't
need a plumber in uh
tuscaloosa but nice meeting you that's
the same kind of thing but one guy's
like dude yeah that's right
my mom lives in tuscaloosa and she needs
a plumber you know it's that kind of
thing like you just keep pushing it and
pushing it you get eyes on it like i'll
go to even little sites that have like
300
subs and i'll be like hey you want to do
a trailer with you and i'll do it and
i'll say awesome thank you that's 300
more people that would never even heard
of me before huh it's really interesting
i know one of the biggest challenges
people have with youtubes these days is
building the audiences and building that
following i mean we still struggle with
it on the corridor crew channel we start
with it on the corridor channel it
doesn't matter yeah how big your channel
is you're always building your audience
it's constant yeah i gotta imagine it's
even more difficult for a film when it's
a single shot out of the blue yeah it is
yeah it is so you know part of that is
you can you can try to get ads and all
that stuff but that costs money and in
our world we don't have a lot of money
we're doing it ourself we're like
financing off our credit cards a lot of
the times so but word of mouth goes goes
a long way another way you can do it is
you could if you have a controversial
subject you could go to the other side
and be like hey did you know this guy
made a movie about devil worship yeah
and then like all the churches will be
like span this movie and then
double the people will see it
so that's one that's smart marketing
yeah
i think outside the box
what is my movie my movie's called the
incantation um it's awesome we shot it
all in france which is really great
yeah you guys should check it out which
part of france uh it's called the share
region like share like the singer it's
sort of central france i i picture it as
south france in my mind for some reason
but it's about two hours south of paris
like right if you threw a dart right in
the middle of france it's right there
okay but it's like castles everywhere
of course it's beautiful yeah yeah
awesome gotta have castles yeah i have
castles
only in france can you just find castles
everywhere yes seriously
uh what's the incantation about uh the
incantation it's about a story a fish
out of water story so like this young
woman goes her great uncle dies
so she gets an invitation to come to
france to the castle
so she goes to the castle and weird
crazy things start to happen and then
she starts to meet people she meets dean
kane and she meets a chambermaid and she
meets myself
i play this vicar which is basically a
you know like rasputin like a crazy
priest you know really demonic looking
did you have all the facial errands yeah
yeah actually my beard was longer my
hair was really long so said this is a
movie they'd like to watch more than
once because there's little things
hidden in it that you don't really get
the first time okay when the reveal
comes at the end you know kind of like m
night shyamalan but like the gender
version but better yeah